[Music]
Deadpool - yeah I couldn't even think of
anything to say for the intro for a
Deadpool to review is [ __ ] up I'm so
sorry so Deadpool 2 is the sequel to
Deadpool a movie that was beloved by
fans and raked in a shit-ton of the box
office - no pressure Deadpool - and in
Deadpool - Josh Brolin plays cable yeah
he also played fan I was having a pretty
good summer that guy he comes back
through time to kill this kid dad pulls
like now I'm gonna save the kids
essentially the plot yeah that's a
terminator plotline doesn't matter it's
also a Deadpool do plotline Ryan
Reynolds once again is the perfect wait
Wilson he's the perfect Deadpool you
just tell the dudes passionate about
being here he works so hard and so
wanted Deadpool one to get made it did
it crushed for him and he feels that
pashtun and Deadpool - Josh Brolin I
thought was great as Stan oh no not that
nose cable even I'm getting jet mixed up
or maybe that was a fourth wall breaking
Joe no I just [ __ ] that but he was
great as cable granted it took a bit to
get cable on screen and after he was on
screen there's a couple times where
you're like there's there's a bit of a
gap between cables whereas cable but
when he's there he's [ __ ] great
also Domino I thought Domino was badass
luck is totally a superpower by the way
the way they showed Domino's powers is
essentially a domino effect a series of
events final destination style that
makes this happen that happened that
happened it just totally works out for
that was really slick essentially
everyone did their part everyone did a
fine job couple of the characters you
loved from the first one take a bit of a
backseat and negasonic teenage warhead
really isn't in the movie much I thought
that was a bummer because I liked her in
the first movie she actually didn't do
much in the first movie also that's why
I was hoping to see more of her in the
second movie and for Deadpool - my main
thing is did Deadpool to make me laugh
that's what Deadpool and Deadpool - are
there for what's this the Deadpool
movies apart from a lot of other comic
book movies is the fact that the
Deadpool movies are comedies to their
core there are other comic-book movies
action movies with comedy in them
doesn't make them innately comedies
Deadpool movies are comedy which I'm
pretty sure is that the same thing about
Thor Ragnarok and yes Deadpool had me
laughing a lot of fourth wall breaking
jokes that you want are in there not all
of them in the trailer yeah the trailer
had a couple lines I weren't actually in
the movie which is not new movies and
trailers have been doing that since the
invention of the trailer I guess it
bothers people more now and Deadpool 2
is bigger than the first movie
undeniably bigger whether or not bigger
means better well that is the question
the answer is no not necessarily bigger
does not mean better this movie at times
seems a bit crowded a bit convoluted the
first movie actually is a really simple
plot news
girlfriend gets taken dudes gonna rescue
his girlfriend and kill the guy who made
him Deadpool - isn't so focused up as
Deadpool one was best I can describe it
is with a die hard movies I'm gonna use
die hard and I have with a vengeance
gonna skip over die hard - because I
think die hard with a vengeance is a
better movie than die hard - die hard
one is a simple movie dude is trapped in
a building there's a bunch of terrorists
there it's gotta stop them die hard with
a vengeance is a movie about revenge
John McClane's going around solving
riddles more set locations bigger body
count so die hard with a vengeance is a
bigger movie than the original die hard
but the original die hard is a better
movie than die hard with a vengeance
that's kind of how deadpool 2 and
deadpool one are and some of the cgi
wasn't so polished I mean Deadpool isn't
known for its huge budget but there's a
CGI character in this movie and I was
like that looks like a couple console
generations in the past ps2 cutscene
might be like launch title ps3 cut
saying just make it a movie you got to
keep your ambitions and your budget in
line with each other
I feel like for a couple of parts
Deadpool to bit off a bit more than his
budget could chew but if you're looking
for a movie to make you laugh Deadpool 2
does bring the laughs has a lot of
references a lot of people watching this
are going to love I loved it too it
handles it like a champ
but sometimes the movies a little
unfocused or a couple of plot decisions
they make that I kind of found stupid is
one in particular I was like that was
dumb I don't like I'm keeping it vague
for spoilers say you didn't like the
call for me Deadpool - isn't as
immortalized as Deadpool 1 but I still
really enjoyed myself with this movie
Deadpool 2 is a great time no alcohol
required so you can have alcohol maybe
one - it wouldn't hurt the experience
you just don't need it to help you
trying to confuse people how's it go
along the meat credit scene was great
there was no post-credit scene at the
very end but the mid-credits scene stay
for that J hilarious I saw Deadpool -
have you seen it what did you think
about it's a little early what do you
hope it is seeing Deadpool - that's a
pretty good one well everything comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]